[Music]
bye
hello yale wonderful
so i want to introduce that
co-moderating this q a
will be professor albert laguna an
associate professor in ethnicity race
and migration
and professor uh quan tran
they will start with a few questions and
then there will also be the opportunity
for you the audience to pose
questions to christina all right i'll
turn it over you
to you too quan all right thank you
diana
thank you christina for that tremendous
performance it took me on a roller
coaster of emotions
and speaks to the power of culture
and the power of our vote so very much
inspired by this
so why don't we start with just um a
broad question
if you could let us know how your path
to comedy
and performance happened uh that would
be a great opening for this conversation
ah well uh you know i
i actually joke that a lot of how i
ended up doing this is because i could
never
find it i mean i wasn't like actually
allowed to see a therapist when i was a
kid
it was very shameful and so uh being
seen publicly was like its own therapy
and i had actually imagined out of
college that i was going to be a very
serious performance artist doing like
dark and twisted things in galleries and
moving slowly
and it would um and do
long durational work and people would
would respond to that work with you're
so funny
and i was like that was my soul like
what was that
so i just began to be introduced more
and more in spaces as
a comedian it was a very scary term to
embrace because i feel like there are
very
kind of commercial expectations of
saying you're comedian there's very like
like it has to look like this and you
have to make me laugh and
and you don't have to be on all the time
but i i think
that's not true it's it's this is just
what my comedy looks like and it's what
it is and
if it doesn't fit your vision of it go
away because i'm
at this point too old to try to wrestle
with making you happy so
so it's only in the last like 10 years
i've been like okay
tell people i'm a comedian and and um
and it means sometimes having a
conversation when people invite me can
you do five minutes on a mic and i'm
like not really because i have this sort
of whole thing i do
um but yeah that's sort of been the
journey but a lot of it has
sort of came out of coping honestly
so christina uh i teach the class on and
racing comedy
and uh you know it's tough classics i
feel like students come like excited
we're gonna talk about comedy then it's
like
more and more depressing as the weeks go
by so look at the history of racial
representation and comedy
i'd love for you to talk about the
strengths and limitations
of comedy for thinking about um for
thinking about race
i okay so this is something i feel like
i've dealt with in a lot of my shows and
why i tend to gravitate towards more
theater spaces is i think there's a
patience
in a theater or gallery space that there
is not in a commercial comedy space
and i feel like in a commercial comedy
space i
i have to sort of play to a very lowest
common denominator
and and uh give my mother an accent she
doesn't have
or uh uh you know you're chinese when
and i
i i feel like in theater the reason like
most of my shows i feel like the first
20 minutes is me teaching an audience
how to watch the show and me
and you don't you don't really get
afforded that time like like okay let me
like very quickly sum up why it is i'm
speaking english and why it is this is
my world view and why it is i'm a
performance artist and why did it be
like
um this one i think i kind of moved very
quickly and i'm just hoping the audience
gets pulled along for the ride and
they're not like well why aren't you a
doctor or like like they they're like
stuck on narratives that they feel they
need to watch me play out
um i don't have time for that i got to
tell you about neighborhood council i
have no time
so i'm just hoping you just come along
for the ride but i do feel like there's
a lot more prefacing
that people of color need to do to kind
of give a little rubric for how they're
read
that white comedians don't have to deal
with um
like that some people just have to
explain what a muslim is right or just
explain like
you know just basic things that that
aren't
taught in the world of culture
great thank you christina um that you
know helped me
raise the next question in the sense
that you have
characterized your work as guerilla
performance and a form of cultural
jamming
could you elaborate a little bit on
these concepts and why you're drawn to
them
yeah so um and this ties back into the
tv pilot that i described which was
going to be this whole gorilla
thing but you know i think very much my
i'm informed by the context i grew up in
san francisco i live in los angeles i
have the privilege of
having been surrounded by a lot of
asian-american centered communities
and so for me to do things like crash a
miss chinatown pageant
is funny in the context of uh
la asian-american culture for most
people the
the beauty pageant queens are crashed on
don't find it very funny but like and
the people running the pageant don't
think it's funny
but you know like that that they get
that that archetype and then i'm
stereotyping it now if i show up in some
town where there's no miss chinatown
pageant dressed as a fake
chinatown and i have tried this people
get really confused and they're like is
this a really a beauty queen like what
is
what's happening is you know and and it
uh and that's sort of what the issue
sort of was with this show that i
pitched was
you know i had was sort of used to
making these guerrilla projects
where i'm have a very specific audience
that doesn't
necessarily know the same rubric that
i'm
dealing with uh nationally and that and
true tv very much is a flyover state
comedy network
and they were they're kind of sheepish
about naming certain political things
and it felt like oh like all these
things i can do in the world of la
are this big for my very patient uh
college-educated audience but people are
people are
still need to react to this and and
like it's almost they can't conceive of
what is she doing like we need
an explanation of why she is like this
first before we can even
watch her do pranks right because
they're they're reading me through a
very specific lens
um so that that uh so so i'm drawn to
gorilla work because it doesn't require
uh me getting permission to get into a
space
i love the the theater of the way people
perform
uh unintentionally i think politicians
are constantly performing
i think everyone who has a social media
account is performing
um and so i i love subverting those
performances i think we've all i'm my
whole theory is we are all
reality tv stars at this point whether
we want to or not we all have the
ability to cancel or be cancelled
um and it's it's a scary frightening
thing we could scream back and feel like
we can tweet back at trump and feel like
i did something when
you know maybe i didn't or did or didn't
but yeah that's that's my interest in
that work
um but i was really drawn to artists who
as i dug through the names i was like
they're all white michael moore nathan
fielder
sasha baron cohen um the yes men
who who do gorilla work and and do
amazing kind of political work and i'm
like where are the examples of people of
color
who are able to sort of invade spaces in
the same way and at least get
commercial recognition or
those rewards and and i wasn't seeing it
so we want to also get the students on
camera to have you ask
yes questions directly so um we're going
to start with amy
amy you got to jump on turn your camera
on hi
hi hi thank you for being here um so my
question
is related to the topic of audience so
do you write and perform
um for a particular audience in mind and
if so do you consider how
intentions may be perceived differently
by other audiences who do watch your
work in good faith
i think about like myself as an audience
member and and
i would try to write something that i
would feel proud of and there's a
certain brand of humor that i
that i feel panders uh and i don't want
to
write that like i i want to surprise
myself in the writing process and feel
like yeah i'd sit and watch that and and
i'm not just delivering up
accent jokes or whatever um i do think
about the fact that i will be touring
colleges a lot because that's sort of
and
the venues i normally tour so like uh
that's why i don't
have a six thousand pound set that needs
to be frayed it in
that's why i like sew my own set pieces
that can roll up and
show up like if you give me the
crappiest cafe and this is what happened
on my other shows which have
tech i show up like to a venue and it's
a cafeteria and i'm like oh boy like
and so for this particular show i think
i was like well i don't want to use any
video and
of course the great irony is i couldn't
even tour it because of the pandemic
and video ended up being the actual
medium
um but yeah i do think about like what i
have access to
and and the situations i'm probably
going to be thrown into
and and how to work with those
parameters so
this is one of the first videos in
videos of pieces in a while that has no
video
um because i've always had some sort of
projection or something and i was like
i'm so sick of
relying on a video projector which
might go put on me um but we did add
some stuff for this because
we can we added the pictures of the dog
and the suffragettes and
uh that was something that was not part
of the live show
is that answer any more questions so
along that line um
isabel has another question um about
audience and reception to your work
isabel go ahead
hi um thank you so much for being here
and performing for us
yeah thank you transformed what i
thought was possible on zoom
oh yay um so my question for you was
there is often the critique of asian
american artists and comedians
perpetuating anti-blackness through
their use of
like african-american vernacular english
and like creation of black culture
um and so forth so how would you respond
to this criticism and how does it
influence
your own approach to comedy and
performance yeah that would have been a
really good question to ask me for my
last show with the long street journal
um you tell me if you i did kind of
track and i think about these things
because i read the critique articles i'm
like i don't want to be a subject one of
those articles
like you know but um but i think it's
it's definitely something that i've been
thinking
about a lot more in my work in the last
few years
uh because of the sort of public kind of
conversation around it
um my last show was the long street
journal and i actually went to uganda
and made a rap album
you want to talk about every landmine
you can possibly fall into
for that criticism that i was in it um
and i didn't intentionally make a rap
album i literally meant
i was going to volunteer and i thought i
was going to write a play about
microloans
and um uh end up meeting these guys
and it was interesting because hip hop
and rap is very much of an american
genre right that that is taken over
everywhere and
i had a lot of critics who didn't watch
the full show do it but i i did feel
like the
in thinking about anti-blackness in the
show and
like someone had once called out that
using the term hella
is using african-american binocular but
i learned that from
asian fobs in middle school in the
schoolyard they would say hello like i
was like wow
i can't use that anymore like it's so
barrier to me um
so i guess i think it i think for me i
don't know
that i can remove everything from my
language but i do want to at least
set up in the sort of the the very
critical first
scene or 10 20 15 minutes as you get to
know me that i have a certain awareness
around certain issues of race that i am
actively trying if even if i don't get
everything right
i am i am actively thinking about that
and
so i i don't know if that answers your
question but but i do think about it i
do
i i feel confused
where some of this goes because some of
it so just some of these things which is
considered african-american vernacular
are so embedded
in how i already communicate i think
just from having living in the city and
and it didn't i don't i never i don't
know i didn't
i don't know where it came from and then
someone explains that that's this is
actually this
aav term and i'm like why um
yeah i don't i don't have a complete
answer to that but i do i
do think that it is something that
comedians need to get smarter about
sort of addressing um when they're
called on it
and uh yeah that's sort of the shift
that i hope happens is that uh i hope it
doesn't mean
we mean like like suddenly erasing
everything in their set but
but at least recognizing that this is
coming up
i feel like this is just that was a
disappointing answer but that's what i
have uh chetan
yeah um question from the acting
performance side of it
what uh to shift gears a little bit um
what differences have you found
like for i mean i've been dealing with
this in my own work but what difference
have you seen for like a zoom audience
and digital for camera work
so many live actually being able to hear
the audience laugh
it's hard it's hard um luckily this
premiered for
a audience in what was the greatest show
of my life in february and i
i was like i felt like i was in my own
comedy special
and so when the shutdown happened
diana's like we could probably still do
it online i'm like no
like how am i gonna go over all this
screaming of like
silence but i uh and the pandemic like
wiped all the lines out of my head
so i had to re-watch the video of be
performing and
that helped me hear the pauses and gaps
for laughter and anticipated i'm not
holding as long
and they were long pauses but um
so that helped but it's i think it's uh
thinking about this the shift that diana
helped direct me that it's not like i am
not projecting
like kimberly gilfoyle becca rnc
like instead it's like it's like hey
it's just you
you at home and me at home and we're
it's much more
intimate so that's the that has been a
big blocking shift
and the fact that like rather than like
clean up my house
and pretend it's a neutral space is to
use sort of the natural dramaturgy of
the house
of like because we can't have a light
change or a shift or
or whatever um and i still have to live
in this space so we just use it
to create new scenes and colors and
shifts and
and then uh and this is what my proudest
thing is is i'm like
i don't have to just remember lines i
have to remember to move things so this
is my
system it's a chair with two tupperwares
that i put this on
and and so it's not just like remember
line and walk i have to remember to move
this
and do stuff like that so it's just it's
a different
vocabulary i'm really glad we got to
premiere it before i i don't know what
it's like to premiere a piece
i mean i do because i'm working on this
sweatshop overlord piece but
um yeah i think it's
it's it's crazy we had we had a uh i
have to learn three i had to learn three
ways to do this one for a live audience
one for my house and then we shot this
on monday
for cameras in the theater but that um
i also had a focus it was a hybrid
between the live show and the
um and the zoom show and that i rather
than look at empty seats where no one's
sitting
i would just directly address a big
camera
so i think uh gabriella is next with a
question
yes uh first off wanted to thank you so
much for this um
thank you i had a question specifically
concerning um
your tv pilot and the distillation of
comedy to wider audiences
um so you notice are you noted how you
had to um kind of like tone down your
comedy and
have your culture become the butt of the
joke in order to appeal to like white or
white
um and so along those lines i was um
wondering how you think media and racial
representation work together
do you think that racial representation
in media especially in terms of comedy
is worth pursuing when we have to change
it so much just to make it make
sense to white people ugh um i think
it's a
it's a pipeline issue of power and who's
in charge and like
i i like it was clear like i think i
could have had a successful pilot if
i got to hire people who
who uh i mean it was just hard it was
all white
gatekeepers in the situation they were
like so nervous it's like you know what
i think you know who i am but but you're
so nervous around
it's like they they didn't even like the
idea of me being too political instead
it was a do-gooder
right like they even kind of like wiped
that down in the pilot
and um and it was just like i think
things just have to say
stuff like you can't
i think i think trying to [ __ ] foot
around words like feminism and stuff
like that
and and just try to pretend that for
middle america it looks like some sort
of
more amorphous vague thing won't work
and that's what they were
trying to do that that rather than name
exact issues that it was just like
christina just
likes to fix and help people and
that became kind of dangerous right uh
in the sense that i
i felt like it i became confused like
wait do i even care about this issue or
am i just am i like dennis the menace
that just comes and
screws up like what real activists are
trying to do here
so it was just a really confusing
process i think we just
we need more more people of color making
decisions at the top and and
making clear where tastes lie
and i i feel like as as as frustrated as
i am that we have to
go to war with everything on twitter it
seems to be one of the few things that
can actually move the needle
that can like wait like the oscar so
white hashtag actually
helped shift to get more people of color
in the oscars
in the voting poll and stuff like that
and
um but it was a tough thing when i was
in that room because it was like i can't
take the
angry college activist approach and go
to war with everyone in this room
because i'm still trying to work with
them
and they still at the end of the day
have this power and that that's that's
what is so hard and frustrating as i
would just
find myself just sort of smiling and
going along with stuff
um and i
you know i've had very few allies like
the only allies were the white women
right like that was like the closest i
could find they like kind of vet for me
and
and they missed things too um
so yeah i i i wish there were more execs
at the top who
uh and a lot of it is those white execs
can handhold
not the white exists the execs of color
can help hand hold
the people who are like oh i don't know
this and like no no it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be fine and that's how
stuff gets moved in like i after radical
cram school the same
web series that alex jones like went to
war with me about
uh disney called us and we were all like
oh my god are we gonna
be able to buy big houses in malibu and
it was it was the low
the low-rung folks who work with the vps
and they're like
we're all about dismantling the
patriarchy in here this is too much but
what else do you have
and i love that like it literally felt
like they opened the curtain kind of
like let the rats run through
and and that was and they were women of
color right but their
their higher ups were white folks so um
so it's a slow long process but it needs
a sh the whole pipeline needs to
shift on up so not even just the talent
but for those who make decisions
great next up we have um dora following
up with a question
hi thank you so much uh on the
note of like alex jones um
what is your best advice as a woman in
comedy and a woman of color and comedy
on like how not to give it
to people like that um and how to
identify whose criticisms
you know yeah i mean you think about who
you care what who's the audience you
care about and play for those crowds so
i
um i get you know when i get invited to
play for more white spaces i get nervous
and i don't turn it down
necessarily but i try to get as much
information as possible to figure out
what i'm going to present
so that um it goes over well but i also
tend to play theater spaces because
those audiences
don't heckle you um where some of these
other spaces will
um but not i mean i i've been uh
trolled for 20 years right since my big
bad chinese mama.com
and i've had people send hate me hate
mails on and off and and it took the
that like that was sort of the crowning
moment of troll dumb
um for me to go you know what
i made it to 20 years of this i can make
it another 20. and
and and if you're going to make an enemy
that's the enemy you want to make and we
also like among our producers we were
like
what are we going to do do we respond to
this do we just delete stuff do we hide
and then we were like let's shoot a
second season
so you know it's just like um but it's
taken this
i don't think 20 years i would have
there so i would just i guess would have
panicked and maybe just disappeared but
i think they want you to go away and you
have to be like
it's a lot of self-talk it's been a lot
of self-help books it's like
i have to still say yes to myself before
i leave the door every day before i want
anyone to say yes
you know before anyone expect anyone to
say yes to me or or give me an
opportunity and i have to like you have
to be somewhat delusional in the sense
like nope i'm just going to do this
and there's going to be lots of haters
and
and what it's a terrible use of energy
to try to bring down people's careers
and cancel people i actually try to
avoid canceling people as much as
possible if
if i can't find a way to be funny about
it um
yeah but i just like go all right that's
a great use
of your time dum-dum so um
yeah but it's i i i i understand that
it's not an easy
thing but i guess that's just 20 years
of building this thick skin
i'm just like you know no one showed up
at the house so i'm like okay well
yes because that's okay and i've locked
down my info and
it also goes in waves like they get mad
at for like two weeks
or a few days and then they move on to
the next person to get mad at an attack
i know it's like it's it's so it's so
terrible like it's just sort of like
yeah that's what it is
but i guess that just
yeah and just make more work and
you know i'll make more shows for this
that people probably be pissed off at so
just like okay
our next question is from uh quay
hi i loved your performance today um
thank you
i was wondering um if you know the
reactions of um
how older like asian american people
engage with your comedy and like what
reactions are
listed from them and um if you know like
the one facebook support group that's
like asian americans with republican
parents support group oh i don't have
one of those i don't have republican
parents i haven't had to join that but
i love that there's how do you how do
you think
we like can comedy how can comedy be
used to dress like political tensions
between like different generations
especially
language barriers or like different i
wonder if my mom is still in the room
let me see
hey mommy you want to get on no
no okay she don't wanna get on okay
but i feel like these shows are my most
honest conversations
um with my parents so
i don't know i don't i know that's a
crazy answer because not everyone
invites their folks to come
see their work um
it's funny how she got on this is my
mother's cameo everybody um
i don't know i i think
how is it just bridge i guess you're
diving for if anything it's just like to
first like i love that the support group
is like other people
with republican parents like trying to
comfort each other right so maybe you
make work first to just comfort each
other like
oh jesus why do we live with this you
don't you're not going to convert them
necessarily overnight or get them to
switch sides
but i think there's something wonderful
and at least going okay okay we have
each other
we might not have our parents right now
but we have each other
i don't know but it's it's it's a
community right we're slowly building
of comfort
thanks christina so happy to see your
mom here uh welcome
and it's great seriously like i you know
i think i wish sometimes that all
all for all of us in the things that we
do we can show our parents
um more frequently um on that note i
think
maybe next up would be hector who
has a question um about well hector can
can can
ask the question
hi uh thank you for your performance my
question is more of
your influences growing up both in terms
of maybe professional
comedians or influences in your family
yeah i think my mother is actually quite
hilarious and my father
is uh he was a sold insurance but he
they would have these like parties like
retirement parties and they always like
do these skits
and even when he turned 40 years old
he'd like lip sync johnny mathis song to
my
mother and i just think like they're
actually quite funny
um don't aren't you funny mommy
okay anyway how sorry how is it
but but just like just really dry
things but i think it was advice but i
think it was just like so hilarious like
i don't i i don't none of this advice
actually works
if i'm not a dead person hiding all the
time
um i wish you'd share a zinger with them
mommy no that's okay
okay all right okay so um
uh what else
uh oh lucille ball i love perfect
strangers
mork and mindy three's company
like all those like really cheesy shows
i grew up tgif like
uh full house um and then like when i
got to college i like sort of sort of
unleashed my angry side and was like
oh look at all this this whole side of
myself i was repressing
this whole time and was so into like
this like dark slow-moving performance
art where people perform in bathrooms
and draw on themselves and
there's no beginning and no end to the
show and i was like yeah i want to do
that
um and i was just like really just sort
of fascinated with this
this genre of work they call endurance
work or performance art and
and uh i think somewhere between comedy
and that
is sort of where i ended up making like
so i still do this show that i can
repeat whereas it's like a lot of these
performance archers you can only perform
once because you only get yourself shot
in the arm once you can only
you know shave your head while you'd
read a poem once
um yeah so i
yeah i feel like it's a lot of that but
i'm really like
i love uh i mean the show i pitched was
like i want i want to do michael moore
meets nathan for you
and i want to like go out and prank
people and um
and and have that edited together and
have this like amazing
final tv show moment that folks see
thank you so our next question is from
sam
hey hello there's another question of
just about um how you envision your
audience
so i know like this show is definitely
very focused on the us but like a lot of
your other
performance work has been around like
asian americans and i was wondering if
you've had any
like responses from asians like in asia
and other diasporic places and how like
they responded to your work
yeah i'll be quite honest my show does
not uh or my my past
work and i think part of me like had
this dream of like i want to tour
internationally i was like wow the asian
american identity
does not really translate well
in other like you got to take it way
down and
real basic and i and so the example i
name is edinburgh fringe festival which
is a big french festival in scotland
and like though i described them as 90s
solo shows about identity
we're doing really well there like this
and then this is a fictitious name for
the show but like the
i'm pakistani uh i'm i'm pakistani in a
woman's show like
like and it wasn't very good right these
kind of shows that
are like these are the different kinds
of did you know we have different kinds
of personalities like
like these multi-character shows that i
thought were like it's not the aesthetic
that i i like
uh went over so well there and i'm just
like this is so stupid
like it's it's like people going oh race
for the first time and
uh and so i did a show called going
green the long way over there and like
the audience was like who cares um
i i did bring the long street journal to
nigeria that was like
some of the audience appreciated those
who work for ngos and stuff like
folks who are sort of living in the in
between appreciated nigerians have a
very different way of watching
us theater like they they watch it like
it's a music concert so they'll walk in
and out
at least my show they'll just text
overly take selfies with each other
and i'm like still talking and i'm like
oh my god this is so
stressful um and and like
a lot of the it just just a lot of the
context just
didn't really like they were very nice
to me but
but it just didn't translate um and so i
think
for this show i was just like i'm fine
i'd rather play the audiences that
really
i feel like i'm myself in and an
audience can can
um dig in on and and and that's
you know like i i don't need to tour
this all over the world
uh i'm i'm fine to just
play this for the context of americans
who understand that we're in an election
cycle right now and that's what this was
for
for me was a show that would and it's
i'm i
dream came true except there's a global
pandemic and maybe fascism coming
next week you know uh but
but i wanted i wanted it to really play
in this context and
uh for an american audience for people
dealing with with voting for the first
time
which is a lot of you folks um
that's that's what i wanted this to be
okay christina last question for tonight
um i'm sure our audience are
curious about what's next for you
in terms of uh performances and work
that you're doing
oh what am i doing next sorry
oh other projects you might be working
on right now
oh yeah it's good so it's running the
auntie sewing squad
uh which is a very different kind of
performance
in that i uh so i sewed all this stuff
and then i first week of the pandemic
was like i'm gonna sell masks
because i'm not essential but if i so
mask i'll be essential and
seven months later our group is still
sewing masks which is
ridiculous because we live in america
why are we sewing masks for people
um but unfortunately it's like systemic
racism it's like
to me it was like this gesture of like
oh all health matters
but it becomes very clear that yes all
our health matters but there are people
whose health is actually way worse
shaped because of this pandemic and they
tend to be indigenous communities black
communities um
incarcerated communities uh undocumented
communities
and that's who we're still working on
supporting the health of so
we're doing this coat drive a warm coat
drive for standing rock i say this
because you're in connecticut you might
have
you might have gained so much
coronavirus pandemic weight
that you have an extra winter coat we
have uh address at auntysowingsquad.com
you can directly mail
your old winter clothes to standing rock
we've just gotten really deep into this
like i was just like this is supposed to
be like a two three week stop gap
and suddenly hundreds of us are still
like running around collecting things so
that people don't
freeze to death um we're getting medical
supplies this day in a rock we're we're
doing relief drives in navajo nation
we we sent a bunch of kn95s farm workers
affected by the fires so that's
that's a project and i think we're going
to be here till the end of the pandemic
we actually have a book deal
which is crazy like something i would
have loved
in my career outside of this but it had
to come down to starting a shadow fema
to make happen um and then i'm working
on a new show called christina wong
sweatshop overlord
which i hope will unfold into a piece
called the auntie retirement party
um so we've been talking about we joke a
lot as aunties that we're gonna one day
retire
and meet each other but it's become
really clear it's like yeah we can just
retire and stop but the problem will
still be there
and so what does that mean to actually
retire and move away from it i think
this is a conversation a lot of
organizations are having especially
theater organizations that
they've been they've been producing
shows at such a rapid pace that they
haven't stopped to kind of check
how white supremacy is embedded in their
leadership structures and their funding
structures and their programming
uh decision making and um
and now is this moment of thing what do
we want to how do we want to
shift forward and for me with the
aunties i'm just like what do we do with
this
community of care that we've created
which has been so powerful do we
continue
do we just walk away and that's it
do we exist as a cultural force like
what does retirement mean
for a group like us so that's
that's a very conceptual piece i'm
stewing on right now
well christina thank you again so much
for this performance for taking the time
to answer our questions thanks to
diane and the rest of your crew for
making everything just
feels so seamless and tight it was i
can't believe you pulled it off
you just think of like a performance on
zoom i kept asking my students like
this is this must be tough right because
there's a thing about yale students
they've all been in theater in some way
when they were in high school i have a
thesis
yeah so yeah that's a very yale thing as
a lot of
like actors come out of yale and come
into yale
yeah yeah i'm talking about that
complexity of doing this
it was fantastic and um yeah thanks
again
quan do you have any parting uh thoughts
thanks for the to the audience everyone
who tuned in really appreciate you
taking the time with the zoom fatigue
um no i think diana you're gonna take us
away
right yes i can do that
let me strike up some music and i think
as we head out
yeah just want to the whole show is to
go encourage everybody to vote so please
yes
vote that's the biggest thing push
everyone who hasn't voted to vote
doesn't matter what for
just get yourself one more if you missed
if you want to recommend the show to
someone this was the last show in my
house before election but center theater
group
is uh we filmed it on monday and it's
going to be airing starting friday it's
only
10 bucks and you get a 30 day window to
watch it
oh oops i sent it privately to cheyton
um
sorry i mean i was gonna send it
somewhere anyway
but but please um yeah like
this is a big experiment for poor
theater companies right now or like are
we tv networks
and so i'm like the first fully staged
show they took a chance on
so please sing it the praises because
it's it's no small thing that they were
like you
christina wong asian woman right who's
in
who whose opinions are what they are
you're going to be the first show
that's fully staged in the series i'd
like to have a big
gold opening and and show their support
for this work
and this way you can share it with your
families if you dug the show this is the
easiest way to share it with everyone
else
thank you jared thank you folks for your
wonderful comments
all right